what makes a bowler so dangerous how can
a virus are overwhelmed they're very
complex defense system of the body so
quickly and so effectively let's take a
look at what Ebola does Ebola is a virus
a virus is a very small thing a bit of
RNA or DNA and a few proteins in a hull
and has no ability to do anything by
itself whatsoever and can only survive
and proliferate by infecting cells to
avoid this we have the immune system the
immune system is super complex so be
developed a visual system that makes it
easy to understand so it looks like this
let's concentrate on the part that's
critical to understanding a bowler and
ignore the rest
so usually dendritic cells would
activate an army of anti virus cells
support cells and antibody factories
that work together with the guard cells
wipe out the infection in a matter of
days but when Ebola strikes it directly
attacks the immune system some of the
first cells it takes over are the
dendritic cells the brains of the immune
system the Ebola virus enters a
dendritic cell by binding onto receptors
for cell transport once it's in sight it
dissolves its outer hull and releases
its genetic material nuclear proteins
and enzymes in a nutshell it takes over
the cell disables the cell's protective
mechanisms and reprograms it the cell
now becomes a virus production machine
and uses its resources to build Ebola
viruses once the cell is saturated it
dissolves the cell membrane and millions
of viruses are released into the tissue
the virus not only prevents the
dendritic cell from activating
respective virus forces it manipulates
it into sending signal proteins that
trick the specialized cells into ending
their own lives prematurely so the
immune system is seriously disrupted and
unable to react while the virus rapidly
multiplies we're talking billions there
are cells that should deal with infected
cells the
natural killer cells but they also get
infected and just die before they can
prevent the disease from spreading at
the same time
Ebola infects the guard cells of the
body macrophages and monocytes not only
managing to circumvent their defenses
it also manipulates them to signal to
the cells that make up the blood vessels
telling them to release fluids into the
body usually this makes sense but in
this case it just causes mayhem all over
the body neutrophils are activators are
woken by the virus and the macrophages
signals they're not very effective
against viruses and should not be
involved in this fight and begin to do
lots of stuff they shouldn't do the
neutrophils signal blood vessels to
release more fluid causing internal
bleeding
another area of the body a bowler
attacks is the liver the virus finds it
very easy to enter the liver and it
quickly starts killing loads of liver
cells and causing organ failure and more
internal bleeding and all of those
things are going on at the same time as
the virus spreads
it's like nukes exploding everywhere one
incident of this in one region would be
problem enough but now it's starting to
happen everywhere at once all the
mechanisms the immune system has evolved
to handle infections work against you
and the virus continues to spread and
spread and finally begins to infect more
and more body cells while the body
desperately struggles to stay alive in a
desperate last effort to turn the tide
the immune system launches a cytokine
storm a cytokine storm is an SOS signal
that causes the immune system to launch
all of its weapons all at once in a
desperate kamikaze attack this hurts the
virus that leaves behind tons of
collateral damage especially in the
blood vessels paradoxically the
healthier the immune system the more
damage it can do to itself more and more
fluid leaves the bloodstream blood pours
out of every opening of the body you
become seriously dehydrated there's just
not enough blood left to supply the
organs with oxygen and cells begin to
die if you reach this point the chance
of you dying is very high
currently six out of ten infecteds died
from Ebola Wow okay
Ebola is nasty so it's time to panic
right no not even close the severity of
a bowler gets paper sold and YouTube
video shared so everybody is talking
about Ebola but currently the only way
to get infected by Ebola is to come into
contact with the bodily fluids of a
person who shows symptoms or from an
infected bat so just don't do that
Ebola has killed 5000 people since June
2014 the common flu kills up to 500,000
people each year malaria kills up to 1
million each year 3,000 people every
single day 10 children since this video
started so even if Ebola is terrible and
scary don't let yourself be scared the
most infectious thing about Ebola is the
media hype around it you could learn a
bit more about the immune system though
[Music]
you